As a function of becoming more grateful,
a person
starts to become more empathetic.
When you are more appreciative of what you have, what you've been blessed with, you can't
help but think about and consider those who haven't been blessed with what you have.
And so um the prophet sallallaihi wasallam reminds us and tells us that you know a
person should consider when when they are thinking about their worldly affairs right their worldly blessings
their material blessings a person should look at those that have less than them.
And when a person is thinking about you know their other worldly affairs things that relate
to their hereafter then a person should look at those who have more than them right
to inspire a level of motivation.
But when it comes to you know the material a person should look at those who
have less
fasting
you know
helps a person be more empathetic because they start thinking about those that you know when
they break their fast they may not have the same things their state or the condition
and the circumstances in which they fast uh may not be as easy or may not
be as um as smooth Right?
Even in the ayat of fasting themselves, Allahh highlights those that you know whose Ramadan might
look different. Allah says
the person who is sick or traveling or is unable to fast then that person should
make it up and if they aren't able to then they should
that person should feed those who are needy.
It's an integral part of fasting.
An integral part of fasting is that you are concerned and you think more about the
needy. And so you know in the month of Ramadan a person becomes more generous, right?
They become more aware of the plight of their fellow Muslim or their fellow human.
A fast that doesn't lead somebody to be more concerned with the ummah, be more concerned
with the plight of their fellow Muslim, their neighbor, their fellow human is a fast that
is lacking in some respect.
um we should as a function or as a consequence of being refined through this process
of fasting, we should be more aware of those around us.
We should grow in our empathy.
We should grow in our in our concern and we should act on that concern, right?
We should transform hopefully ourselves but also transform the lives of those around us to the
extent that we can.